hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
las caravanas de emigrantes que viajan
hacia eeuu volvieron a encontrar una
barrera en mexico unos 14.000 efectivos
de la guardia nacional fueron
desplegados en la frontera sur del país
para detener el paso de los que iban en
tránsito los migrantes fueron
dispersados y hubo rechazo ante el uso
excesivo de la fuerza que usaron las
autoridades para hacerlo contra grupos
en los que incluso viajaban familias con
niños el gobierno mexicano reconoce sin
embargo que su política para contener a
los migrantes no es suficiente y en
cambio le pide a eeuu apoyo a proyectos
de desarrollo en la región y visas de
trabajo para los que emigran en busca de
oportunidades esto fue lo que pasó
durante la última semana en mexico
sin respuesta a sus solicitudes de asilo
y cansados de esperar un permiso de
tránsito los migrantes volvieron a salir
en caravana hacia eeuu
formadas en el sur de méxico buscaban
avanzar hacia el norte estamos cansados
[Música]
febrero
no podemos sobrevivir aquí en tapachula
qué hacemos aquí estamos porque un
indigente solo queremos pasar la mayoría
de los que emprendieron el viaje en
grupo eran haitianos y centroamericanos
no hay trabajo no no no no ha trabajo en
tapachula la persona no puede vivir e
imagínate a la persona durmiendo para la
calle pero la guardia nacional
desplegada para contener su paso
rápidamente entró en la acción y lanzó
redadas en las que detuvo a decenas de
ellos
[Música]
algunos migrantes se enfrentaron con las
autoridades y las caravanas fueron
completamente disueltas quienes pudieron
escapar esperan seguir su viaje en
solitario o en grupos más pequeños
el accionar violento de los efectivos de
la guardia nacional ha sido duramente
criticado e incluso agentes del
instituto nacional de migración fueron
retirados de sus cargos sin embargo el
presidente mexicano reconoce la política
contra los migrantes
el propósito es
mantener hasta donde sea posible a los
migrantes en el sur sureste del país
porque
permitir la
introducción
significa muchos riesgos
pero aunque lópez obrador defiende que
su gobierno respeta los derechos humanos
lo ocurrido en los últimos días pone en
entredicho el trato real que se le
brinda a los extranjeros esta no es la
primera vez que méxico envía a la
guardia nacional a custodiar sus
fronteras lo hace desde el gobierno de
donald trump y ahora con una nueva
administración la historia se repite la
llegada del ioba idem a la presidencia
alentó nuevamente la migración hacia
eeuu y sólo desde enero méxico detectó a
casi 150.000 migrantes en condición
irregular en el país
entre el grupo de emigrantes que fueron
dispersados había cientos de haitianos
que migran desde países de suramérica
como chile o brasil y para eso cruzan
naciones como bolivia en su ruta hacia
eeuu pero su paso no es fácil y muchos
denuncian abusos por parte de las
autoridades más de 5 mil 400 haitianos
entraron a bolivia de forma irregular
desde enero hasta agosto de 2021 el
informe de nuestra corresponsal meriva k
esta es la frontera de bolivia y perú
según fuentes oficiales acá llegan cada
día alrededor de 400 migrantes haitianos
tras cruzar el territorio boliviano
desde brasil una travesía llena de
dificultades que incluye extorsiones de
parte de algunos policías corruptos
según la denuncia de ronald peters
bolivia está maltratando a los haitianos
eso es en todos los lugares por los que
pasamos ellos nos piden dinero
si uno no paga 20 dólares 50 no nos
dejan pasar en donde eso pasa
ronald es uno de los migrantes
afortunados porque consiguió pasar al
lado peruano al contrario este año más
de 5 mil haitianos fueron detenidos en
bolivia y deportados en su mayoría hacia
brasil 5 mil 418 personas hubieran
pasado por el territorio nacional de
manera irregular estas personas han sido
intervenidas
tras las críticas al maltrato el
gobierno ha firmado un decreto que
permite a los haitianos quedarse en
bolivia por dos años pero la mayoría
solo quiere seguir su camino hacia perú
una solución consistiría en darles
visados humanitarios para evitar que
sean expulsados hacia las fronteras por
eso es importante considerar esta
temática y ya en fondo dentro del estado
a través de la amnistía a través de la
visa de tránsito a través de la visa
humanitaria pero principalmente en la
región para que los estados comprendan
que cierre de fronteras se está
generando delincuencia en este momento
unas soluciones que sin duda habrían
ayudado a ronald ya sus compatriotas a
cruzar por bolivia sin problemas sin
embargo los operativos policiales
prosiguen contra migrantes haitianos en
su travesía hacia perú otro hito en su
ruta hacia eeuu los esfuerzos por
contener la migración no son una
solución real a los problemas que
provocan el éxodo detener y deportar son
medidas de fuerza que seguramente
llevarán a los migrantes a intentarlo de
nuevo
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]